look we did a lot we did a lot of
research for this movie and you know a
lot of it was was with Jack about
paleontology and dinosaurs and a lot of
it was about animals on our planet right
now because we wanted to make a movie
that could be about our relationship
with animals in the way that we treat
them in the way that we we do put them
behind bars and we we use them in
agriculture and in medicine and in war
and certainly two of those four ideas we
utilize in this movie so the idea of an
animal that's raised in captivity who
doesn't know its mother has in this case
eaten its sibling and and therefore is
has a bit of a you know psychological
issue and then goes on on a killing
spree was something that that we did
think a lot about and it wasn't
specifically just that at there there
have been other circumstances of animals
breaking out a tiger for example
breaking out of captivity and that tiger
had never seen another tiger or really
another animal and it became a serial
killer and just killed everything that
moved and we thought that was a
fascinating idea and and like a lot of
things we thought we could attribute
attribute these these animalistic and
tendencies to two dinosaurs Tim I want
to talk about the visual effects the
first film was obviously a landmark not
just for what Stan Winston did
animatronic land we'll get to that but
in terms of what ILM was able to do and
what visual effects were able to do are
there shots in this movie that you
wouldn't have been able to pull off
three years ago four years ago there are
a lot of shots I'd say that we couldn't
do you know four years ago the creature
work on this you know we we've modeled
these dinosaurs with full skeletons in
them they have muscle structures on them
they have skin all of these things are
firing and moving like a real animal
would we we applied some new
technologies such as motion capture for
the Raptors and we were actually
publishing some papers and there's gonna
be some papers at SIGGRAPH this year on
some of our retargeting techniques we
actually cast four people at ILM as the
four Raptors
so any time that we needed you know some
action for blue we would bring that
person down to the motion capture stage
they would suit up suit up meaning put
on put on a motion capture suit and we
actually had a backpack that had a tail
on it that they could and they would act
and we would in real time be able to
retarget their
performance right onto the Raptor so we
could actually see it as the Raptor
rather than the person signing onto a
film like this you you never really know
how a filmmaker is gonna handle
something like this technically because
I mean this is the amount of invention
that's required on set in order to do a
film like this is profound and things
are things are new things are being
tried out constantly and so there's no
kind of rote way to handle you know a
filming when you know that a lot of it
is gonna ultimately need to be done in
post some incredible incredible tools
that that Colin provided all of us is is
first and foremost the environments were
real so this wasn't us shooting in a
stage in a green-screen just kind of be
like oh you know I mean it wasn't that
at all
it was it was us in an environment in
the jungle in heels in the jungle and
and it was us actually shooting in a
park that had been built in in in New
Orleans there was an abandoned Six Flags
park that that that we took over and
built Jurassic world so our environment
was very real and then there were actors
performing the roles of the Raptors so
we were responding to real performances
and we worked with the animatronic
dinosaur early on and I'll just give you
an indication of how real the
animatronic dinosaur was it's I mean
essentially it's very it's really kind
of emotional thing that happened which
is that Michael Crichton passed away
very very very very suddenly and you
know his family didn't have a lot of
time to repair and his wife was eight
months pregnant when he passed away and
so his son John Michael never never met
his father and and and I know his his
wife and a little bit and and you know
just you know always heard stories about
John Michael and how extraordinary is
but it's just um you know it's an
unthinkable tragedy to never meet your
father so he I knew they were planning a
visit to come to set I didn't know what
day and then I come to set the day that
we're working with the animatronic
dinosaur and and that's the day that
they show up and John Michael goes up to
this dinosaur that is so lifelike I mean
there are
there are so many puppeteers there
operating this machine I mean it is it
is chillingly real and john michael went
up and looked looked at the Apatosaurus
and turned to his mom because mom it's a
real dinosaur and it was just like it
was just it killed me because you know
this is the gift that his father has
given all of us and this is the gift
that he's now given his son because this
never would have been in existence
without his story and so anyway it was
just the the we had experiences like
with the animatronic dinosaur that felt
so real we were in a real environment
there were actors it felt so so real and
it took such effort on their part to
give that to all of us the most
important thing really was the indominus
and we gave him a lot of Liberty and and
I think you know the coolest thing about
this is when we started Jurassic Park
one the first one we didn't know at that
time whether we could get DNA from a
dinosaur and we tried and we were and we
failed so we know now that we probably
can never make Jurassic Park the way
Jurassic Park was made but when it comes
to indominus rex we actually make
transgenic animals now so so Jurassic
Park its Jurassic world is actually more
accurate than the premise of Jurassic
Park
we want to know where those animals are
Jack tell them about the chicken well
the chickens a whole different story so
yeah well we're actually trying to make
a dinosaur birds are the descendants of
dinosaurs and and so we are actually
trying to retro engineer a bird back to
a dinosaur in real life I hope it's not
a very distant Island we're not close
we're not gonna let we're not gonna let
Colin get close to it I think the movies
suggesting that there are a lot smarter
than we give them credit for is that
actually accurate as well that is
it's a paper that's actually in process
our next paper and and it turns out
dinosaurs actually have a much larger
brain than then people have known and
we've actually known it for a long time
but as weird as it sounds and you've
heard it before dinosaurs actually have
the brain in two parts
they have cranial brain and they have a
pelvic brain and if you add that if you
add them the volume of them up they
actually have a brain to body ratio
similar to most mammals how important
and how did you go about creating what
these dinosaurs sound like because it's
a performance unto itself well I wish we
had I wish we had Alan and some of the
guys from Skywalker Sound because
they're they're the professionals in
that area but you know there there is a
new roar for the indominus rex that
utilizes you know howler monkey and i
believe there's some walrus in it and
there's all kinds of different new
sounds and in each of these roars
historically and i'm new for any of
you've you know seen any of the stuff on
how to ask a park was down there it's
it's not just finding a specific animal
it's one recording that was made of that
animal on a specific day and you can't
get it to do it again there was a sound
that a baby elephant made I believe in
the first tragic part that was
incorporated into the t-rex and I think
Ben Burtt just got it and they loved it
and they said oh go get a bunch more of
those and he could never get another one
and same thing happened I think with a
walrus sound that we had on this Pete
Horner and Al Nelson who are our two
lead guys up there had had captured this
sound and and they've they've learned by
now that once you have it you know that
was it it was some some strange noise
that was made and and there they become
extraordinarily adept at working all of
these noises together all these sounds
together into something that's
completely new how does it feel to have
gone on this journey on Triassic park
over so many years and have brought this
new dinosaur forth it's an incredible
feeling
obviously thrilling really because I was
a little bit part of the first Jurassic
Park and watch that become what it did
but to sort of now introduce Jurassic
world to a whole new generation and and
that's been the most fun for me is to we
had a benefit at Jack's for Jack's
museum Museum of the Rockies if you're
in Bozeman Montana please visit last
Wednesday and I was so excited to see as
many kids in the audience as adults and
it played for both so to be part of that
and to be able to bring this now to a
whole new generation and bring the
dinosaurs back has been a thrill you
know and when we were in the very first
conversation that we had is I didn't
want to make a fan film I didn't want to
make something that that was derivative
because it's so iconic because we all
know that movie so well and yet it does
have a very specific cinematic language
to it and it has a look and a feel that
it gives you so you know I wanted to I
wanted to you know create the feeling of
Jurassic Park without actually you know
recreating Jurassic Park I wanted to
instead of following and in Stephens
footsteps to to create a new set of
footsteps to the right and maybe
slightly respectfully behind